super excited to welcome Ron Funches
everybody rock that's right hello Chad
Ron Funches do we ask rich bods it's the
one and only Ron Funches
I'd say we're gonna be playing overwatch
on the old xbox one so if you got a
complaint with us just add a gamertag
Blair got to put a way to get the chat
hey shady what's up heads good to see
you
white what does that say wicker tunnel
wicker tunnel I'm sure that's a
euphemism for something good to see you
today it's our last date Comic Con we've
been streaming all week and tonight I
think we have the cast of Suicide Squad
yeah yeah you got your Jared Leto's or
is it Leto Jared Jared L you got your
Jared oh you got your your Margot
Robbie's your Will Smith's your Triple A
- exactly yeah we got a bunch of Will
Smith's coming hello TJ mom jeans good
to see you
hello Tori M what's up yeah so we're
playing overwatch today and you're
playing Evo right now right Eva diva and
fancy diva you said you saw someone
cosplay diva I did Oh Mandy was my
favorite I feel like diva has to be one
of the best what I would like to see
somebody with Hansa or is it Hanzo but
the metal links would be insane
what's have you seen what's the best
cosplay you've seen this year I mean I
think the diva was really good I've seen
a few Harlequins but that's normal
that's terrible for this - this season
this time of year exactly mr. J I hope
she says that have you seen Suicide
Squad yet no no no that's special
you got that Shiv is magic all right
let's see if we can uh let's see if we
can jump into a game with some fans so
if we can uh how many Deadpool's I
haven't seen any temple no zero
Deadpool's this year last year though
lots of Deadpool's but then the movie
came out and it kind of who summit heads
heads wants to marry you
with who though they didn't say who who
what do you mean heads oh they were
saying they're talking about you earlier
it's got awkward yesterday Deadpool is
awesome who's your who's your uh who's
your favorite comic-book character you
come [ __ ] I would be the new comic book
show called powerless yeah I love you PC
to be determined
[Music]
I'll of it Subway's awesome ah let's see
here
alright so I think we got a custom game
I'm adding these people don't disappoint
me people let's get in here I'm gonna
invite them boom oh look at this Vlad
won we do max AI you can't you like big
games or small games like full games man
all right let's do max both add them up
add them up add them up do you want to
trade off deaths how do you feel what do
you use one play will trade off games
yeah oh you play I would rather try the
player are weak I would play all we have
a rather
shady asked rod who would win in a fight
Superman or Thor what about I will say
though what if it's on some kind of like
a like planet home there we go
but far like like yellow Sun yellow Sun
ok the thing is like Superman is
susceptible to magic which store has so
I feel like I'm authority might take the
cake on this yeah that's two plus he has
super speed here's one thing I will say
about in comic books I feel like super
speed is always underutilized and
underrated as a superpower that is a
very powerful one I've used the most
yeah things like Superman has super
speed but he never really uses it you
know like for instance in Wilmington the
also has the flight you know right
[Music]
that's right ron funches and guy fieri
playing overwatch i'm guys brothers gary
fear oh yes what at what show are you
gonna be all right okay bucket list at
least how was it doing them what kind of
cookies did they ask you what kind you
made cookie cupcake is amazing
lovely nerd lady with the girls you gave
up you nicely
yep I will say have I seen over watch
porn says nakeds yeah oh I haven't seen
it yet no is it is it a lot of a great
I'll tell you that much what it's just
it's just a bunch of Rinehart's no
mostly it's a lot of widow-makers like
let's get a little weird let's get some
torrents in there oh my god everybody
does a lot of squats in this game a lot
of glute work my favorite is a May I
feel like that Parker under that big
winter coat absolutely great but
absolutely oh yeah heads once Wow heads
just won't let go of Aukerman yeah great
we noticed your heads way to go odds
odds Oh a tracer oh here's your question
Oh your feet with your favorite cake to
make my favorite cake to make yeah my
son likes to make like a blue type that
it's a vanilla cake but with this blue
tide I like the great blue Dini like
kool-aid okay I mean I am that oh that
oh man great blue Dini because that was
the one that changed colors that blew my
mind do you know about that bother you
too young great blue Dede was a kool-aid
flavor I'm going old school where you
would make it and then like 30 seconds
later it would change I think it was
insane and finally you shouldn't have
been ingesting it I think that was about
that a bad idea exactly
yeah like rainbow cake oh my god
Ron are you touring anytime soon you go
90 tours there we go doing some show you
do in show used in improv comedy works
yeah I'm in DC at their Improv gym
favorite cities you like visiting I like
oh yeah the Pacific Northwest action up
there if you're in Los Angeles I have my
show at the Roxy on Saturday July 30th
instead Midnight's got midnight
merriment we dress up old Hollywood
style music and come marry me Camille
Nanjiani is on yeah what Bobcat
Goldthwait Emily Heller Sam J a while
they're so funny Bob Kaazing check it up
at the Roxy years July 30th midnight
somebody asks what video games are you
excited about now or in the future
no man man they finally you see the
picture they finally finished it there
[Music]
dude please please bring Red Dead back
at my house what's up by the way what's
up it's for that game is great my faves
I have you played inside yeah I highly
recommend inside quality I love it
awesome a Marvel or DC more weight to
kick you turn what is powerless and how
they have to deal with the aftermath and
issues you know when people are going
through messing up coal cities yeah
everybody else and still has to live
world and have regular lives and regular
job oh that's awesome
I play rock that's money that's gonna be
easy to figure out on a script guys
that's for Danny
Oh Danny so funny that's fantastic I
feel like that'll be especially Danny
they'll be you guys made me be able to
do a little bit of improv that would be
awesome
bear ski hell yeah DC all day baby DC I
like I will say though I'm liking the
more I like the Marvel movies a bit more
I haven't seen Suicide Squad yet I'm
like Nolan's stuff obviously but I think
Marvel is kind of figured out you know
they're big guys I just got tickets to
go see The Killing Joke yeah I hope
suicide I'm really looking forward to us
that's good no man's sky the game every
big company is trying to stop me but
still half-life 3 i haven't played
half-life 2 or half-life
I've never played halfway because now it
kind of feels like the graphics and that
stuff you get a little bit I mean
there's a fun about it being like it
doesn't hold your hand and it really
expect you to be an adult you know wait
silly like sure exactly
[Laughter]
really
Oh what do you think
Carrie yeah that's true it is very like
early eighties guy fear you will play
death stranding just to see Norman
Reedus
I love the kijima it's awesome so I'm
looking forward to death stranding it
looks insane
I gotta play half-life shady says I'll
try I'll try ah binary Merrill I played
no man's sky I got a little taste of it
was really it was fun it can merely be
combat no I didn't get in any combat but
it was it did kind of seem like you know
like kind of like minecraft or you can
just make it your own and go super deep
that's what it felt like to me like you
can I ran late
yeah really yeah it felt like less of
like a just like let's kill things I'm
more just like wow this game is more of
an experience also I would love for them
to put that on like a VR situation oh I
didn't get to do that how was it it's
pretty fun I like it it's but still you
know it seems more like that you know me
it was a demo so I guess that makes
sense
yep you know it's gonna be fun to see
what type of foolish games that we can
get out of it I'm interested to see like
they haven't quite figured out the
movement yet a lot of those will tree
while we train I will trade off deaths
next time okay I'm tell every time we
die what's your job cuz that means
you'll still basically play the entire
time as I die but but yeah I'm not into
the teleporting thing like when you hit
a thing you teleport down the hall it
takes me out of it you know yeah we do
yeah I really like the yeah much I'm a
much more fan of like I'd rather be in a
box like with the HTC like 5 or because
I like being able to move around yeah
it goes like I mean it's really a real
Tecna frames per second on this psvr
yeah Rob would you rather be smoked by a
canada's planner eaten by red licorice
well yeah I get it Doug eat my own red
licorice
my red licorice is even me yeah it's a
your red licorice you seen you I did oh
yeah that sounds it's to eat ones that's
terrible yeah I mean I guess if any red
vines
yeah burn yeah that'd be horrible like
you're asking to be chopped up for birth
to death that's terrible yeah so you
said this is a weird game of StarCraft
yeah this is a pretty odd Starcraft this
is a new expansion pack against dark
[Laughter]
Tron c3k we are is a last day streaming
from comic-con burn down here we've got
Castle Suicide Squad on the show that's
why we got rods of great Ron Funches
here playing game playing games man no I
knew all their schools are new Witcher
unless which was great there's a lot of
little things in Witcher it's very
specific
a lot of items so many potions yeah yeah
I'm a big fan of Skyrim
Grinch mode lol Ron at the best yes he
is
that's right thank you will you go back
out getting dug with high again probably
he says a lot of love for Ron Funches of
course yeah what has been the greatest
thing you've seen at a Comic Con
what a tease you're here you can't like
walk around Oh have you walked the floor
yet no I'm gonna do it after I leave
here so many Harlequins exactly
hey Mikey Warrior what's up thanks for
joining us Robert Jenkins yeah well if
you have you ever done any cosplay you
ever dressed up like any characters and
is that cosplay video you did a great
thing for us when we did our Star Wars
show you played Lando Icarus yeah
amazing cake yeah you Oh glorious hair
with with TJ Miller and I should Tyler
and II played dengar and Conan played
Lobot lowjack Lobot no LoJack is what
happens in the car alright so I think it
was a little odd yeah Lobot yeah if I
could put a link yeah then Jabba's job
as assistant Oh poke a look I love you a
nun dateable rod exactly exactly
Thank You dungeon blaster that's very
nice to say we're doing good Mikey
warrior yeah I don't be I've been
playing all I've been playing all week
it's great hey Omar what's up I even
play pokemon going all down here
yeah plus it kills your phone battery I
need I'm wrapping this is a sad thing to
say but look I love Pokemon I look
[ __ ] like oh yeah but is love we're
hooking tournament yeah about that yeah
there we go
leave that game exactly
Reptar mom yes I think another clues
gamers coming soon yeah dude we were
busy Wow
well done victory whoo guys are playing
rough oh geez if you want to play yeah
let's back out well I wonder if we can
add some other people Oh rabbit otter
says Ron what's the weirdest or funniest
fan encounter you've had so far you're
you a beloved character beloved person
when I come up to you I'm sure a very
very nice to have you had any kind of
weird or anything except as they linger
the linger is interesting when leaders a
little hanging out that is I think we
can let's see let's invite these how do
we invite these people playing overwatch
cool cool that where is cold anybody
sleep yeah if I was yeah I'd be asleep
above us in for sure how can we get
these people in can we just
I'm just trying to add folks see ad
players I don't see a couple people on
here you have the atom through you your
xbox first no that's a good question
well I think if I go up here let's see
this might be this oh I see
can I sit X y no oh maybe you have to
view their game ricard xbox man inside
and Red Dead Redemption was a current
can currently only play on xbox so there
we go that's change I'll prove that
that's true my playstation with me
because it's smaller so let's see oh you
did oh nice I love you yeah we travel we
have this giant case that we are playing
okay all right let's get out of here
we'll just invite the same people oh
here we go
wildmutt's got in yeah maybe I do it to
invite them that way oh that's a
terrible thing I am too
thank you yeah I love it man yesterday
it was crazy hot down here is humid
everyone was just like we were all like
a sleep in the offices freckles and
things in here it stinks into work sucks
actually likes he feels like comfortable
yeah yeah it's pretty hot we got to do
one by one sorry folks
[Music]
it undateable was amazing hey what did
you what did you learn from doing
because it was alive which is kind of
interesting
yeah so that but you perform a lot was
he or was a harrowing at all I mean do
you now have a jonesing is it going to
be the same now that you if you pre-tape
stuff that's still acting involved yeah
but it was a fun experience something
that we'll always be able to look
finally back on
proud of because I feel like you know
even in the fact that it lasted three
seasons it was a show that people were
like we don't even know this pile is
gonna get picked up yeah that's what the
last three seasons to me is amazing
he'll work with Bill Lawrence to some
he's exactly you know like Chris and
Brandon we still have a group chat that
we do on text oh that's great Ricky's
birthday today happy birthday twit glad
the Glassman shout out I got loves
American Ninja Warrior he does he is
obsessed we had a long conversation
about that where he we were talking
about he went to somebody's they make
some of the guys who go on and Wrekin
into where have made jungle gyms in
their backyard yeah they've got it done
stuff yeah that's insane that's awesome
but they should make American Ninja
Warrior but for video games for guys
like us I'm not coordinated at all like
why I'm a giant head and it's just like
I'm top-heavy I can't let skateboarder
yeah so the American Ninja Warrior just
right in the water
exactly uh [ __ ] take oh do you what's
the walking dead walking no my son is a
big anti-zombie guy anti-sub yeah yeah
nice well he should
[Music]
yes I've been watching a lot of strange
things
oh how good is that I'm only four
episodes in so have you finished the
whole thing yet I fell asleep watching
[Laughter]
Slayer dark yes Pelorus was the
co-creator scrubs absolutely yeah I
can't wait
Oh a view scene you know and you see
Zapotec horseman I just started watching
it I loved it
I'm a big mr. robot fan I'm happy that
that's back that's the theme song
originally kappa deez nutz yes this is
live and you have an amazing day
stranger things yeah there we go Oh bear
Sookie's been watching stranger things
one of the line at the con that's crazy
here's a good question if you have you
do you ever get stage fright
I mean sometimes an overly good stage
fright I guess I get nervous before
every show you get stage arousal mostly
from working with daliyah like oh they
used to kind of always be like oh man
I'm just I would treat each show kind of
like a bank robbery experience to be
like no no I'm pretty good
well and I'm like that's better better
confidence has been helpful for my stage
miios days lately you might be like he'd
be a little more confident Ron Funches
yes show to Elite Ron is lost but you
wait how much you got you said this on
the show yeah at last check and candy
laughs it probably man Wow
congratulations that's great that's
awesome one of the things is a lot of
weight to one of my favorite things is
now I can wear more like crazy shirts
and stuff yeah exactly you could really
dress you can really weird out and dress
I love this shirt by the way
that's awesome let's bring him back a
lot of Captain Planet good job Ron yeah
everyone yeah a lot of congrats to rock
that's right ah Master Splinter six mr.
Funches wanted to play overwatch so to
the fans we're playing with Ron Funches
right now you could thank him because he
chose up for watching today that's right
game a choice man game a choice has that
changed as has your weight loss changed
how you what you do on the road now cuz
you have to be a little more conscious
about where you're eating in that stuff
yeah yeah or mindful about things
whatever yeah dark now UFC yes we're
playing on xbox one so sad Blair's the
gamertag we'll get you in a game with
mr. punchy that's awesome what would be
one of my favorite things about
comic-con is it feels like everyone it's
like our people like we come back and
it's
it's all you know like people we you
mean corporates yes but I what if
there's a from your childhood you wish
that they were reboots what show with
that small wonder oh that's a great
answer man so I wonder for those who
don't know was a show where there was a
little and I don't know how what was
them the premise was she was a robot
robot named binky she was made and why
do you remember why that's a dark but
you know what's crazy one small word it
was an effort to assist handicapped
children Oh
and so right soon as the robot it was a
robot little girl loved his family but
the last episode did you do you know
what you must know about the last
episode super dark where it was and I
didn't know this I just I'm weirdly I
read about this just like a couple weeks
ago cuz I got i went on a wikipedia
rabbit hole you know how we do it like
three in the morning and so there was
how we knew and there was a an evil
robot as counted towards the end there
was an evil
it was Vicky right is it an evil Vicky
and at the very end she takes like good
Vicky and like swaps with her and puts
good Vicky like in a closet and then
that's how it ends is the family gets
like an evil robot and then like they
ended it was super dark it was crazy
amazing a lot of these cartoon reboots
haven't been great cop cop Teen Titans
Powerpuff Girls yeah I heard that I
heard powerful good I love teen things
go is great yes sons favorite cartoons
maybe it's not for you yeah exactly
maybe it's for children oh boy men look
a lot of Korean love I can't read
of your day spas of hope it's nothing
that sense calling Korea yeah yeah I
think so I think so we got although they
would love overwatch too
there we go our game a flu shot butter
hey aunt pencil not good to see you a
lot of love for Beth oh Anthony Harris
the support love Teen Titans go you are
wrong
exactly technically right I mean that
actually might be the first DC sitcom
tell you the truth it's untrue it's a
pretty good it's like a pretty good
sitcom oh that's awesome
I gotta check it out this is great Roger
you play fighting games you can find
super excited for injustice I hope my
new overloads at DC sucked up power that
you're just this is gonna be the
greatest thing for you oh man swag is
gonna come come in hot and thick oh yeah
that game is crazy how the good graphics
I love that injustice I can't wait for
the new expansions are fun - Jason I
think and it's really good
expansions I was awesome free hookup
Batman better than Superman
I do like Batman better just because
yeah he's right exactly and he's and
also like he does having these
superpowers he's just a really angry
dude is so angry you know uh and also
he's a tactician he's a master
strategist which I I I respect that yeah
you know what Superman kind of just
shows up but it's like what's up you
know like I think yes do you read powers
at all do you
so super shock is kind of their take
Fitness's take on Superman it's super
shock spoil or it goes crazy at one
point because he's like like that
one of my favorite books irredeemable oh
yeah uh mark we sat murkly yeah d well
it's great which is just like a super
anchor who's just like insane like who
just goes nuts and there's like trying
to stop him but he so he's all-powerful
Superman oh that was so crazy that's
awesome
Astros fan says I ron has a hilarious
WWE making Akram self is that true maybe
the Beast Boy cyborg friendship is great
on go my nephews on the spectrum of what
goes where those times just gets to be a
kid oh I love that yeah it sounds like a
really great sitcom that's awesome I
love things that are well written it
doesn't matter what what it is
yeah community Superman chameleon
forgets his cars mid vowels that
creators can add fake attention that's
true it's to be Superman like it's kind
of unfair I love it move Corrigan - what
do you think about the meaning I am
really pumped although I heard it's not
gonna happen wrestling a second of
Nintendo wrestling excited to happen
through HDMI one of my big issues about
yeah when they play older games that
they don't have a TV that yeah we'll
play it properly you got to get the
weird like double adapter thing that
looks like a feeling and it stretches it
out that doesn't look great
well somebody said great job on the
Nerdist polling episode yeah before and
after school when I used emulators
instead of buying mini NES because I
want to somebody comes out with a good
product I want to support it
yeah also
open it little girl be like hey you
wanna play this emulator I don't think
that's gonna work
yes yeah that's a terrible way to try to
get somebody into bed emmalin and as
soon as you say emulator the girl hit in
the door she exactly
I've not gotten the new lootcrate
favorite Nintendo game oh this is tough
man I don't know favorite Nintendo game
good God
I mean I loved like Double Dragon I
played forever Ninja Gaiden but I could
never get past when you have to fight
your dad there's that one part we have
to fight your dad used kicked my ass oh
yeah ah Spile oh love Ronnie so
hilarious he is favorite rappers Kenan J
balloon is asking I'm really into run
the jewels right now
love me some run the jewels we did a fun
thing with school like you asked we
asked - what is what is a weird fear is
he's really scared of raccoons raccoons
is there good cooter like get my
traction yeah yeah they come at you like
a bad guy I'm coming to like a new man
alright they got a little thumbs they
can use guns they get like we're their
little you know they got opposable
thumbs man I don't trick plus they're
like like nature's like bank robbers I
got a little bit is that carry like a
little sack with money run around a
reblog people are message become
I love it
uh you're the best king of mortis shady
gemma is the person who handles our
snapchat uh new Justin Bieber album
haven't heard it I will say though I
really like the new town album I'm not
lying
it's uh you might want to get into that
that's right this is a safe space and
save space you guys the safe space
exactly space yeah get that
O'Town man they're back guys Oh towns
back just waiting for some new Smash
Mouth that's my new thing that's right
Siraj should be honey which country are
we taking the show to after South Korea
that's a surprise we're not gonna tell
ya we found Atlantis we've all been
practicing
Raj spoiler alert it's Atlantis they're
still down there my favorite Suicide
Squad member whoo that's a good question
I mean I love your dead shots yeah I
love your I don't know that's a really
good question what about you Suicide
Squad members how the Quinn's great just
a great pair I mean she is amazing opens
England may be Shady
uh Alan JLA you're welcome thank you for
watching Oh
narcos season two narcos I kind of
didn't get into it look Freddy kind of
kind of lost my interesting would you
pick dark learn odd Japan to be awesome
at you ever been to Japan no but I was
thinking about going for Christmas Oh
what's them what's that that's their
WrestleMania that new Japan
whoa - good wrestlers in the world are
usually in Japan at that time period
make a bunch of different fun shows oh
that's awesome
wait what are the monkeys do like get
you towels and stuff yeah think so
that's better
you don't want to anger them maybe
probably the game banana chips play the
game that wasn't sure what not that was
a great play yeah Oh probably cause it
was like a triple kill
oh no game guys up your game
no that's guy will definitely play no
one's got El Diablo's great enchantress
is good too because she's unpredictable
I don't know how she's gonna be in the
movie though I hear weird you're weird
things like she's not gonna harley yeah
I love I will say we're up turn-off I do
love Harley and Batman the Animated
Series is amazing that's like one of my
favorite characters mr. J I just love it
Batman theme in series that way I've
seen so it's a classic
we lost people here let's see if we can
add more folks here and more folks what
do you what do you uh you have a
favorite Oh your xbox favorite your
favorite console what you do do handheld
stuff or not really not much lately
I carry my PS with me but I don't use it
do you ever do the spot by the the
StreetPass thing where you get how does
that work you get extra you check it and
then you get like fun little prizes and
little puzzle pieces pretty good but
lately I just been
busy but either late I'm either working
or I'm at my house lack Jax of Red Dead
Redemption trying to pass the time
trying to pass the time
did you I'm sure you must have played
the zombie expansion right yeah oh man
it's so fun pass the snacks over here
[Laughter]
you're gonna be short-handed this time I
think you can handle it in your just put
it down you are the man mr. Funches are
you gay there we go those snacks what
you're so I have my soft spot for snacks
even with weight loss Cheetos
I love Cheetos I love a crunchy regular
cheat oh I don't do this flaming hot I
don't do that keep those with too much
too much it's like crack cocaine only
more delicious what's your favorite
[Music]
[Laughter]
flamey hot is where it's at soccer man
you're wrong get out of the chip leave
the chatter now oh mac and cheese
Cheetos oh I can't even yeah what are
you doing exactly
exactly she's the Geno's we went one day
one went back at late night like five or
six of us drove super early to
Philadelphia and ate cheesesteaks all
day we had six cheesesteaks we had two
for breakfast - for lunch - for dinner
it was awesome but it was crazy because
like so we had passage eNOS at 9:30 in
the morning then we went to chubbs
because our supervising producer Tracy
King used to live in Philly so she gave
us like she's like oh you got to go too
you gotta go to this just for fun with
the jobs and then we went to Delos ah
grows and then we're all like this is
great this is great
ten minutes after our fourth cheesecake
we've all passed out in the car we just
like fell asleep slept for like three
hours won't give it like seven they
really got tell you more cheese sticks
that went to gyms and I came from the
last we went to and it was awesome it
was so fun we like when you're like all
cocky and then we just like if we drove
back just all bloated like sweaty just
smelling my gal do we all went like Wiz
and onions peppers and it was just that
cars stink it was rough awesome he's got
the munchies chocolate-covered coming
very sure they come steak and cheese all
day baby all day
whoo tell us your favorite snacks yeah
we're the cheesy moths at delicious
cheesy buys a lot of cook hello Korea in
the chill-out YouTube chat is blown up
it is always sunny Philadelphia it's
always cheesy Philadelphia I love it hey
hoody TV what's up we don't let
streaming every monday starting at noon
to 1:30 pacific time but not this Monday
down here down here we've been oh my god
with the red Winston at whoa dude red
Winston Red Hulk yeah
still a monkey though yeah but he's like
a man he like grew up on the moon is a
sign to care airhead can't airhead bites
candy that's just taffy man area is an
area that's just happy yeah like plastic
oh but my son loves their heads so
parents are delicious what about
warheads though um sour
they're super sour stuff I can't do it
about gummies blowing about stretchy
holy low damage it we did a thing if you
play have you done that thing where I
also like the chunky bar it's basically
a cereal you think about it not that
much is different Rock the goldfish oh
yeah anything kind of like crunchy and
cheesy I'm into you man that's that's my
jam that's my jam hey swag master what's
up what's up you master in that swag
[Music]
swag Chico are you like a new clutch
fingers and that stuff quick figures
yeah like juju what I have a lot of pro
wrestling figures but they're just in
boxes in my house they live with an
apartment still and I don't feel like
it'd be pretty weird to pull out all
these figures yeah did you do any
statues or anything I think a couple
I'm gonna go look around today is he
baby catches my yeah but I mostly like
I've always been like I like I like
everything a little bit but yeah yeah
Italy don't know any actors or actresses
malicious Joker there is a show on TBS
tonight Suicide Squad I'm all Oh craze
aura has all the wrestling figures and
the wrestling ring you know it's crazy
archly cheese fries so you gonna be
started uh chili cheese bread that's my
favorite like my cheat meal is like I
like a good cheeseburger and some chili
cheese fries yeah oh my god oh my god
yeah it's real West Nile okay it's not
hot gas
[Music]
do you remember you still making a Super
Mario maker
oh woodsey oh my god you had some great
levels so you make you it's like I get
bored real quick too many games not
enough time
exactly yeah exactly I'm gonna follow
Ron right now again followers on Twitter
Ron's trees made me happy there we go
play a lot of overwatch there's the link
oh dude you I do watch twitch oh they're
not really
some of my friends that's cool hopefully
if I'm like just crazy we were already
talking yes we love the little Nintendo
the NES that's coming out we're all
gonna grab it Oh Crocodile Dundee that
should be a that should be it that
should be let's do a Crocodile Dundee
video game man there's gotta be one
right
that's not a nice Ron man be your friend
someone wants to be your fire
all right there you go now your rice
fried lightly that's it mayor yeah
exactly
who someone's asking can you say boo
yeah like sigh Boyle I 29th a minute
cartoon movie there we go
I love it
uh what dark tonight a UFC will try to
get you in the next the next game we're
trying to get people in just add me
Blair on xbox I have me now edge man are
you a fan of any of the Final Fantasy
games they've such been a big sort of
beat it if I have to start with five
never played any Final Fantasy is there
one particular one I should start with
so who's asking Oberon if you play any
Arkham games you just said you did the
Batman VR experience a crotch ARAG what
what is the what is the demo what do you
have to do in the demo you go into the
Batcave you talk to Alfred for a little
bit you try out your weapons that was it
oh wow oh that's interesting yeah yeah
and other knee are you excited about VR
but mostly not really on the console and
I'm excited about it for PC and try
oculus because I feel like you have to
have pretty powerful make it even work
so I don't really understand how the
psvr is gonna do it but I've never seen
rod this angry yeah the reason why I
want to get a house Oh somebody said
junk rat is basically Crocodile Dundee
with explosions that's true that's good
yeah let's pick some people up let's do
it all right we're gonna get some folks
in open it up what do we got spray spray
spray spray
everybody loves fries and bottle those
braids take all right great
shirt get them skins get them screens
get them skins yep
you know Widowmaker it's just we got
over here voice line out it sort of all
the Winston people are saying that has
do people tell you that you nope I've
never gotten that in my life not once
this is the very first time I was at a
wedding with Paul Giamatti one time it's
a really nice guy very very very
pleasant as a person very pleasant as a
person all right
let's get some more folks the people who
just added us we'll invite them into
this game goodbye to a game well I like
to invite to keep song if I do the game
we've all put on the play nothing don't
curse a it's great
I like making up little songs it's just
I love making sorry
yeah it's like Thank You torrei yay
thank you :
I'm working hard sometimes though late
at night to stone do they can what are
you seeing the show that you were to eat
gummy bears and spitting all right it's
gonna be the last game Ron Funches yeah
do with him as Susie gets back it's
whippy cream
there we go Adam in here we go boom go
there we go
are you a me guy or not I'm a little bit
a little bit I forgot them name I'm in
reading some things and reading one
punch man
which I like more than the anime
electricity forget the name of it so I
can't even when it's about a guy who
dies and he ends up in an RPG type world
and but he's kind of a jerk and he has
three ladies that are his party and
they're all that like one special skill
if you know the name saying than chat if
you know that name name of that show
sorry the stream is so short everyone we
have to because we got to do a show
today suicide squads on tonight the
panels happening right now yep exactly
after this is done go check out that
bump up a panel is it locked
vlog horizon 3-0 sorter like it like it
have Japanese name or humans a computer
simulation pirate primate I think we're
probably all a computer simulation I
feel like that our house did we make BRE
right I agree I agree I don't know if
this is common sense be it's just common
sense not want to use either really like
a lot of fun love punches love yeah I
feel like we're not the Keystone reality
I think we're probably some kind of
simulation of some future some kind of
future either humanity or some kind of
alien dude Eduardo says I know I do run
was a week ago stubble AHA bit you did
and Laugh Factory and binge washed
everything you've done since oh that's
awesome they're in a deep punches hole
punches rabbit oh yeah still got new
material a new Mexi row 3-1 hello right
back I love it foster family says hi
we villain knew via my god overwatch
it's great Blitzer did an awesome job
[Laughter]
I'd like to get alright there we go
perfect
people love ya people love rotten I love
you they don't love you yet how many
times have people told you the best
laughs are you play - I play rocket
League I play a little bit of Rockley
but not good at soccer I can't seem to
do the thing everyone does where they
shoot up in the air and do crazy yeah
exactly are you gonna hit up the Tekken
tournament yes Ron Funches laughs is
pure joy basically light it's like
seeing a unicorn it just makes you happy
oh you know what what is your Grinch
part is asking what is your opinion of
his new not new but like Dark Souls
blood-borne these like really hard
brutal games I'm not sewing today
like I've been the heart but not in the
kids things being like where they don't
were they like we don't want to explain
this to you right Oh sometimes but I
don't need hand-holding but at least
like notice something to see that they
assume that you played the whole series
yeah I agree I just want to check it out
I agree that's kind of why I liked
inside cuz that game I didn't know
anything about it and if you haven't
played it don't know confuse you yeah
don't look at yeah exactly it's really
fun it kind of there's so many moments
should whoa like crazy yeah there you go
moments that game might be my favorite
game of the year so far
yeah me definitely purveying it for sure
I came in this game exactly the bucket
list slabs include earning a Funches
giggle and having Rickles call you a
hockey funny right mine is to talk to a
girl for more than five minutes yeah
it's gonna happen one of these days just
can't but yeah I just like maybe I'll
try you know why she's got nowhere to go
I'll dress up like one of the
Silverhawks with a thing and get in
there
exactly appreciate your list game on
there we go I have not seen the teaser
trailer of iron fist I think you mean
the defenders are you have you seen them
any of those Netflix shows daredevil i
watch their adobo i like the first
season the second season the writing was
a little weird
yeah yeah we got I'm really looking for
Luke Cage
I love he's one of my favorite comic
characters I was growing up so I'm
pumped to see ya when he goes to the
hallway that look pretty go
exactly play Han so that we can't play
on so this is the last game we're almost
done with mr. Funches have any questions
get him in now I know I'm not gonna be
exactly I like to just spray and I wish
Winston's whitening gun was a little
more powerful but I understand why it's
now I will so this game is really bad it
feels very balanced it's like whatever
kind of character you play I think if
you're good you can just you can put the
beat down contesting point
do you watch Rick and Morty love circuit
board I love we need a felonious Gucci
mash up kind of surprised it would tell
I'm I get around matchup between between
the Beach Boys and to Paco they're
bigger beach boys are so smooth
it's so smooth waffles or pancakes or
they're just Coltrane's great Oh Ron
who's Davis who's the most of all most
famous person you've met but who's
someone his timbala yeah okay so when
you would get starstruck by or you've
been starstruck by I start shucks when I
met Becky Lynch yesterday yeah there's
no wrestling she's great it'd be weird
things like that professional wrestler
Ric Flair and probably Oh Nature Boy the
Nature Boy himself it's I will say it's
interesting like I think I'm not sure if
this is true or not as well but kid
people who I loved when I was a kid I
will always be stars yeah like Myra to
meet MacGyver I would be stars yeah like
Bruce Campbell was on the show the other
day yesterday or two days ago
did a great bit where he came out
anybody sandwich with his chainsaw arm
it was really funny blood came out it's
really funny I was hugely starstruck I'm
a dark just what I feared with his evil
dad huge fan loved that show by the way
all those scary zombies in there so
maybe not in it but that's show yeah ash
vs. Evil Dead is great yeah I think
they're like Stephen King kill them all
are you PC gamer do you play PC no but
I'm interested in that's why I wouldn't
do it very nice PC unitl reality so you
better ski zap Tashi I love Pokemon go I
think it's a it's a great idea I'm bad
at it and my phone kind of sucks so it's
not the greatest for me to play but I
think anything you know it's cool people
yeah yeah exactly I feel the same way I
feel the same way I've been taking a lot
of photos of coding I like taking
screenshots when I catch a Pokemon it's
like a Honda Hume yeah I do like taking
a lot of those yeah oh those are so some
of those are on my Instagram if you want
to get coated looking at some Pokemon
which is Larry's chicken strips or
Nuggets oh it's thick breading of that
that's good I do I mean chicken why I
always again McDonald's Nuggets oh my
god hang out yeah I was in Vegas one
time and I ordered 16 chicken nuggets
and the kitchen clapped when they
brought him out to me and I was by
myself it was no no it was in the casino
it was one across in the Bellagio it's
like kind of a crappy one oh it's all
beige inside it was called the Monte
Carlo okay it was amazing it was in
their food the Monte Carlo food court
and I wasn't even drunk I was just
really hungry I guess they come in those
little boxes and by the way fun fact if
you get 60 chick Nuggets to give you as
many sauces as you want they gave me
like the order and they should I hope
that make their rent strips holla oh I
think we're evenly split on strips and
nugget although I respect a good strip
yeah oh my god respect against chapter
16 chicken nuggets 60 what a noob oh my
god yeah Doug life like life I'm gonna
be like Tupac just get like an ugh life
and I'll be beat up immediately yeah by
chickens chickens will be like you
those it that's of my family the thing
is here's the thing and I know this is a
small thing and this is super weird I'm
even talking chicken the boot McDonald's
nugget fits perfectly in the sauce like
it just it's so satisfying you know
that's the one you get to get the last
little bit of sauce out of the thing we
haven't even launched yet every good
Oh nicest yeah there we go
strips with a win get up for that I've
done worse you're right do either of us
watch H 3 H 3 and H 3 H 3 is what is H 3
H 3 Chris law I look at both the YouTube
chat and the twitch chat so I see you I
see you friend what games we gonna play
next I don't know I bet one game should
we play uh ron has said he's currently
playing some Red Dead Redemption
right good I might actually we might do
that on twitch at start plates of Red
Dead yeah cuz that game is I would
definitely play that game again all the
way through john marston man got a look
at once when I really first had it I was
a poor comedian and I would make bad
purchases choices and then something
what happened there was a gig is a gig
like a good but I needed high-value
trade yeah just gotten into mexico house
with my big screen TV in this porque
would not trade nothing in yeah watches
everybody
awesome awesome thank you for joining us
for this dream gun Cup it's been amazing
follow Ron on twitch twitch on TV slash
Ron Funches you can get the morning wood
that's right powerless comment on any
[Music]
follower on Twitter Instagram there we
go Ron Funches overall media okay yeah
Cupcake Wars he's gonna make some
buttered popcorn cupcakes it was the
other one
cookie dough cookie dough amazing little
sample cupcakes awesome
and we will see you guys not next week
the week after watch the show tonight
suicide squads on thank you guys for
joining us have a great comic on
everybody
you